des caméras piétons pour équiper les
policiers c'est la solution la plus
régulièrement mises en avant par
l'exécutif pour résoudre les litiges sur
les violences policières ça n'a pas été
facile à mettre en oeuvre mais ça y est
pour le président on en voit le bout
d'ici à octobre l'ensemble des
engagements pris en la matière de ses
trente mille caméras seront toutes des
plaies c'est une véritable révolution je
rassure aussi pour les plus experts que
nous avons changé les contrats jadis
passé et que pour ceux qui n'en n'ont
pas encore bénéficié ne s'agit plus des
formidables caméra qui marchait quatre
heures par jour début 2019 en pleine
polémique sur les blessures provoquées
par les tirs à la tête de l bd 40
pendant les manifestations de gilet
jaune christophe castaner le ministre de
l'intérieur de l'époque annoncé que
chaque policier équipé de cette arme
porterait sur lui une caméra piétons
presque trois ans plus tard la mesure a
eu énormément de mal à se généraliser la
société en tout cas elle qui a fourni ce
matériel à qui avait été choisi un
produit un maintien qui n'était pas du
tout adaptée qui donnait vraiment de
très mauvais résultats et au final qui
n'étaient pas utilisés qui lassé dans
les placards de la part des policiers
est très souvent remise en cause et par
le son par la captation du sang par la
captation de l'image ça permet d'établir
en tout cas les réalités des
interventions qui se pratique et puis
les éventuels outrage provocation dont
font l'objet dans son victime très
souvent que nos collègues caméra piétons
c'est pas une fin en soi mais c'est un
outil qui est important par cette remise
en cause aujourd'hui qui est perpétuelle
parpaings par rapport aussi à cette
guerre des images dont la police est
très souvent victimes côté manifestants
des doutes persistent aujourd'hui la
plupart par exemple pas les chats des
gilets jaunes des violences à l'encontre
des manifestants qui ont été filmés si
je prends ma propre affaire que même
avec ses preuves la même en ayant les
preuves qu'il ya eu un tir c'est très
compliqué pour pouvoir obtenir justice
donc que l'on filmé c'est une bonne
chose ça permettra d'avoir la vérité et
la transparence sur d'éventuels
problèmes que peuvent rencontrer aussi
bien les policiers que les éventuelles
victimes mais il faut il faut derrière
que la justice puisse accélérer aussi
est
de justement pour pouvoir s'accélérer
d'avoir toutes les pièces en bonne et
due forme pour que transparence soit
faite et justice soit rendue cette fois
c'est 15 lyon d'euros qui ont été
alloués pour acheter trente mille
caméras avec des batteries qui pourrait
tenir 12 heures soit bien plus que les
modèles achetés précédemment qui tenait
entre 2 et 4 heures un bond qualitatif
qui permettra aux forces de l'ordre
selon un syndicaliste de pouvoir se
défendre de façon plus équitable alors
qu'il dénonce depuis plusieurs années la
diffusion d'image de violences
policières tronquées ou montés sur les
réseaux sociaux qui ne reflèterait pas
la réalité selon eux